Mình cho ngoài uống ngày 20,5 thông qua ngỏi trường phạt mới nhẹ vào Iran, nhằm đến các ca nhân và tổ chức phát động
họ thực hiện trình dịch trân án bạo lực huy bường tình và biệt tên Iran hỗ trưởng nè
có ngoài trường ngày uống đặt đồng thuận chính trị về việc đưa lực lượng về biến kính mạng oi sạo Iran
vào dân sách có tổ chức khổ bố, lính sống xưa thấy đổi mang tính biểu tượng trong cách tâm cận của châu Âu đối với dưới lãnh đạo Iran
ngoài uống cũng trong ngày 20,5 thông tần Rồi tân giãn cân một tình trường biết
Mỹ đang cân nhá cơ phần án ra tăng xức áp lên Iran, bao hộng khả nắng biến hành các cuộc tấn tâm có mục tiêu, nhằm vào lực lượng an ninh và giới chỉ huy
với mục đất là đẹp lãnh sống biểu tình tại Iran bụng phát trở lại
các hộn tình của Rồi tơ xử biệt, tổng thống mi đưa nân trâm chưa được giác quy định quý cộng
sau việc Mỹ trên khai tổ sân bài, cộng các chiến hạn với trường đồng đã mở giật đáng cạnh là lực quân sự của Washington
chứ đáu tổng thống trông cũng cạnh bạo Iran nên đạt được buồn thỏa thỏng nghiên bởi Mỹ
nếu không muốn chừng đồng tâm tâm tâm ác liệt thân hồi tháng xóa nơi ngoái
về việc Iran dởi trước cho biết đăng trình Mỹ cho khả năng đối thổ quân sự
đồng thời vẫn tìm cách duy trì các kinh quảy rao
tây Iran khẳng định sẵn sẵn đối thoại, về vẫn đẹp nhăn chính thơ sử tôn trọng lượng nhau
nhưng kịch báo sẽ đáp trạng chứ tưởng có vào Mỹ's Realm và cơ đứa đồng mình nếu bị tâm tâm